la côte d'ivoire qui compte plus de 3100
cas confirmés a elle décidé de se
tourner vers les plantes médicinales
pour lutter contre le coc vite 19è les
détails avec sibel à tamba ghislain
mendoça et mehdi est ce que si des
remèdes à base de plantes médicinales
hérité de traditions anciennes
voilà la solution majoritairement prôné
en côte d'ivoire contre le coronavirus
pour des raisons culturelles et
économiques près de 90% de la population
ivoirienne aurait recours à la médecine
traditionnelle
les quelques 7000 tradipraticiens que
compte le pays sont fortement sollicités
il propose pour certains des remèdes
censés soigner ou atténuer les effets du
co vite 19 cela se passe à quel malade
sur ses étals d'un marché d'abidjan les
feuilles de margousier remporté un franc
succès tout comme l'artemisia utilisée
notamment contre le paludisme
ces plantes sont vendus à des prix
accessibles de nombreuses personnes sont
convaincues qu'elles peuvent les aider à
éviter d'être contaminé par le
coronavirus je suis une pointe quelques
feux de nîmes bon enfin de laisser à
titre préventif contre la maladie la
pandémie encore navires us bah moi je
pense que jusqu'à preuve du contraire
les médicaments traitant le palu en
effet positif sur cette pandémie
parce que jusqu'à preuve du contraire
quand pas de choses qu on n a pas là de
le chloroquine de l'artemis ya ben c'est
tout ce traitement de palu encore
pourquoi pas pour ce naturothérapeute le
comité 19 n'est pas une maladie nouvelle
selon lui des solutions existerait pour
la guérir avec une potion à base
d'argile et de différentes plantes qu'il
a lui même élaboré
il prétend pouvoir obtenir une rémission
complète au bout de quatre mois au terme
de cette période le virus disparaîtra
totalement du système immunitaire selon
lui qu'en bas du colonat vieux riches en
cours à que ces nouveaux noms le russe
est un vieux riches la grippe c'est un
devis riche et donc les virus sont des
êtres mutants et comme ça développe les
mêmes c'est pourtant comme je viens de
vous le dis le rhume la grippe et
l'angine la toux alors j'ai des
médicaments pour soigner toutes ces
maladies là et donc j'ai fait un pour
joe cole pour soigner tous ceux qui
viennent et qui développent des
symptômes là en côte d'ivoire un
programme a été mis en place au sein du
ministère de la santé en 2015 objectif
tenter de concilier médecine moderne et
traditionnelle
un projet auquel a pris part le dr crow
a écoulé ce dernier affirme que dès le
début de la pandémie le gouvernement
ivoirien a sollicité la contribution des
tradipraticiens ainsi ils ont été formés
pour relayer les gestes barrière dans
leur communauté
les remèdes qui l'ont développé lors de
la crise doivent néanmoins être analyser
et valider cros et où les pense que la
solution peut venir de côte d'ivoire 90%
de la population utilise les médicaments
à base de plantes et c'est long les
statistiques également les praticiens
que nous avons dans notre base de
données
reçoivent auprès de 3000 patients par un
pour dire que la population voudrait
avoir une solution
à base de plantes pour ceux qui aiment
bien la médecine traditionnelle
plusieurs dizaines de produits seraient
actuellement en phase de test au
ministère de la santé de l'hygiène
publique
aucun à ce jour n'a prouvé son
efficacité contre le coronavirus